tiens et un de plus un cadeau au revoir
tian bonjour je suis inquiète
françois et casimir sont partis ensemble
il y un long moment et ne sont pas
encore revenus
bon alors enfin à mon avis il vaut mieux
que je le donne comme ça comme ça ou
alors comme ça comme ça oh oh là là
avait dit dont le premier était pas mal
mais le second manquait pas de charme
qu'en pensez vous ouais le choix est
difficile à howie écoute je vais aller
demander à sabrina pour savoir si je
peux être fier de moi
enfin une idée sabrina à casimir j'étais
inquiète tu sais où étiez-vous bonjour
bonsoir jour sabrina et j'étais en train
d'aider casimir et sur secret qu'est ce
que c'est bon sabrina je voudrais te
faire écouter un 1er que j'ai composées
tu en as écrit toi même la musique
ouais écoute
bravo casimir tu peux être fier de toi
on pense comme un grand musicien
remercie sabrina je suis très content de
ce que tu me dis là mais tu sais ça se
danse aussi l'asie ouais ouais bien qu'à
finir c'est encore mieux comme ça tu
sais je voudrais sabrina te faire
écouter un autre morceau de musique que
tu as aussi composée non cette fois
c'est un un grand compositeur
j'écoute alors comment trouves que
satair pas formidable tant grand
musicien n'a pas beaucoup de temps et
est même si je le pense estelle
je suis désolé casimir moi c'est pareil
sans grand musicien ne s'est pas
beaucoup fatigué j'ai tout entendu
casimir quand tu as dit à sabrina que tu
était l'auteur du premier morceau elle a
été surprise parce que de ta part
s'attendait pas quelque chose d'aussi
bien plaît quand tu lui as dit que tu
étais l'auteur du deuxième morceau alors
là elle a été très déçu parce qu'avant
d'être un grand compositeur
ben faut beaucoup travailler mais je
comprends il ne faut jamais se faire
passer pour plus fort que l'on est au
contraire bien raisonné casimir à
monsieur du snop
monsieur du snav je vais vous faire
écouter une musique dont j'ai composé
alors ce n'est pas très brillant bon
pour vous casimir
mais attendez attendez monsieur dix neuf
et demi enregistré un autre morceau
écrit par un grand compositeur à
l'écoutons ça
oh que c'est beau ça c'est de la musique
quelle dureté quelle délicatesse quelle
pureté rose troqué la pureté que je t'ai
dit m enfin tu l'as fait écouter le
passage où je suis tombé au milieu de
tous les arguments